in deutschland ist es trocken und die
natürlichen wasservorräte sind nachdem
der sommer 2018 vielerorts noch nicht
wieder auf alte stände zurückgekehrt
andreas friedrich meteorologe vom
deutschen wetterdienst sagte am mittwoch
wir haben momentan sehr geringe
bodenfeuchte am extremsten ist es wieder
trocken im osten thüringen
da ist es jetzt schon trockener als im
sommer letzten jahres wo wir die dürre
arten und insofern stehen wir momentan
vor der situation dass die
ausgangsposition im moment schlechter
ist als vor einem jahr also der böden
sind deutlich trockener als im frühjahr
2018 unter der wetterlage leiden vor
allem die landwirte zudem ist es in den
letzten tagen bereits in ganz
deutschland zu wald und moor bränden
gekommen
feuerwehren im ganzen land mussten
früher als gewöhnlich zur
waldbrandbekämpfung ausrücken
hartmut ziebs präsident des deutschen
feuerwehrverbandes sagt hierzu also das
ist eigentlich eine insofern
ungewöhnliche herausforderung zwei jahre
hintereinander so eine extreme
trockenheit
das hatten wir lange jahre nicht die
feuerwehren sind aber darauf vorbereitet
das heißt wir können damit auch gut
umgehen
allerdings bräuchten die brandschützer
zusätzliche ausrüstung für waldbrände
also wir müssten bei der
luftunterstützung noch ein bisschen nach
steuern
das heißt aus unserer sicht gibt es zu
wenige hubschrauber die zur
brandbekämpfung aus der luft geeignet
sind
hier wäre schön 110 bis 20 neue
hochschule zusätzliche hubschrauber
hätten bei der bundeswehr bei der
bundespolizei den länderpolizeien
notfalls müssten wir auf private
anbieter zurückgreifen die es aber auch
schon gibt dass die wehren selber
fliegen de leschten unterhalten sei
nicht geplant die unterstützung durch
bundeswehr und polizei sei bisher
ausreichend für die oft langwierigen
einsätze in wald und moorgebieten
bräuchten die feuerwehrleute auch
leichtere schutzkleidung die nun
angeschafft werde eine sprecherin des
innenministeriums sagte am mittwoch der
deutsche bundestag habe zusätzliche 100
millionen euro für die jahre 2009/10 bis
2022 bewilligt um ausstattung für den
katastrophenschutz und die brandschutz
bekämpfung anzuschaffen laut dem
deutschen wetterdienst ist es zunächst
jedoch noch offen
ob sich eine trockenperiode in diesem
jahr fortsetzen wird oder nicht
für die kommenden tage sind zumindest in
teilen des landes niederschläge
angekündigt